[Musique]
sur twitter comme autour de nous au
quotidien
les avis divergent beaucoup concernant
le vaccin contre le coc u19 est une des
questions qui ressort au cours de ces
débats est la suivante les vaccins
favorise-t-il l'apparition de variants
on y répondant facture
[Musique]
avant de répondre à notre question
faisons une petite piqûre de rappel
concernant le fonctionnement des vaccins
[Musique]
lorsqu'on se fait vacciner contre le coc
vite 19 avec pfizer ou moderna on va
entraîner les cellules de notre corps à
se défendre contre le virus dans le cas
du sart skov 2 il s'agit de combattre la
protéine spahic qui correspond à la clé
du virus pour entrer dans nos cellules
en se faisant vacciner on apprend à
notre organisme a fabriqué cette
protéine spike pour produire des
anticorps adapter la prochaine fois que
notre corps sera exposé au sart skov 2
il aura appris à envoyer des anticorps
pour combattre l'infection et maintenant
on va se demander d'où viennent les
variants
les variants ils apparaissent tout le
temps dès que le virus se réplique qui
fait des erreurs il fait des bêtises en
recopiant son génome c'est comme ça que
ça crée des variants ou des virus thion
quelques mutations par rapport à leurs
ancêtres apparaît en permanence et plus
le virus circule plus on a des chances
de voir apparaître des nouveaux variants
ces variants ont deux types de mutation
les mutations qui ne change rien ou
presque et celles qui vont augmenter la
dangerosité du virus et sa propagation
ce dernier cas de figure correspond à
l'expansion des virus appelé préoccupant
use of concern en anglais et ce sont eux
qu'on appelle les variants alfa beta
delta et gamma mais pourquoi ces
variants s'impose-t-il par rapport aux
autres
ceux qui vont survivre c'est ceux qui
sont avec les meilleures propriétés en
théorie ou l'environnement données et
donc quand on est en début de l'épidémie
ça est simplement ceux qui sont les plus
rapides à se transmettre et ça c'est
encore ce qu'on voit et est ce qu a
largement contribué à l'apparition des
variants préoccupant et ensuite
hypothétiquement ans pour une situation
où les nouveaux variants qui seront
capables d'avoir du succès ce sont ceux
qui auront échappé un petit peu à la
réponse immunitaire de des gens qui sont
sera vaccinée soit qui ont déjà été
exposées et ces variants ont tendance à
apparaître dans des endroits du monde où
la couverture vaccinale est faible la
couverture vaccinale c'est le
pourcentage de la population qui est
vacciné au sein d'un même pays par
exemple est une problématique entre
alors en compte celle de la couverture
vaccinale mondial très inégale et c'est
là où c'est un petit peu stressant c'est
que évidemment dans les pays qui sont
favorisés il ya déjà des vaccins est en
partie aux populations qui vacciner donc
le virus y va ralentir sa sa circulation
et donc il y aura moins de variantes s'y
risquent d'émerger dans ces zones là
mais par contre dans plein d'autres
endroits où il ya pas de vaccination là
le virus y au poids répliqué à pleine
puissance et donc faire plein d'erreurs
et avoir des chances de faire à part et
des nouveaux variants qu'ils pouvaient
avoir des nouvelles propriétés et cela
s'ils sont réintroduits dans les régions
où il ya des gens qui sont plus ou moins
vacciner il pourrait être confronté un
environnement où par hasard à un de ses
variantes qui a dit va avoir du succès
parce qu'il est capable de se propager
dans des populations qui sont vaccinées
pour autant est-ce que les vaccins
favorise l'apparition d'un nouveau
variant est ce qu'il y a un lien entre
l'émergence de ces variants et la
couverture vaccinale d'un pays
absolument aucun au contraire même les
vaccins limites l'infection du virus et
on espère dans certains cas la prévienne
plus que presqu'entièrement est donc
dans ces cas là le virus a moins de
chances de se répliquer et comme il a
moins de chances de l'expliquer il a
moins de chance de créer des nouveaux le
temps et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans plusieurs pays dans le monde
bien que le vaccin contribuer à diminuer
l'apparition de nouveaux variants il
existerait un seuil qui serait propice à
la création de variants plus résistants
aux vaccins lorsqu'une grande partie de
la population est vaccinée selon une
étude publiée dans la revue scientifique
scientific report sur le 30 et ce seuil
se situerait justement à 60% de la
population
lorsqu'une majeure partie de la
population est vaccinée en particulier
la fraction à haut risque de la
population les personnes âgées et celles
présentant des pathologies sous jacentes
les décideurs et les individus sont
tentés de revenir aux directives
prépandémique et au comportement propice
à un taux élevé de transmission du virus
c'est là que des variants résistant aux
vaccins ont le plus de chances
d'apparaître puisque l' immunité de
groupe n'est pas encore atteint on parle
alors du phénomène de pression de
sélection plus le nombre de personnes
vaccinées augmente plus les variants se
montre compétitif pour augmenter leur
capacité de transmission malgré cette
vaccination aujourd'hui près de 50 % de
la population française est vaccinée
nous nous rapprochons donc de cette
fameuse barre des 60% reste donc à
savoir si la population française se
fera vacciner rapidement pour passer ce
cap puisque le but est justement de ne
pas stagner autour de ces 60 % mais bel
exemple d'atteindre une couverture
vaccinale de 90% synonyme selon la haute
autorité de santé d'immunité collective
[Musique]